with the clock ticking down as you
mentioned for a relief bill
to be passed by congress let's check in
with a member of congress it's ken buck
of colorado
he's also a member of the house
judiciary committee and a member of the
house foreign affairs
committee congressman thanks so much for
being with us you heard there from david
spunt that nancy pelosi is going to put
it to a vote increasing those checks
from 600
to 2 000 how will you vote on that
potential bill
i absolutely in favor of giving the
american people two thousand dollars i
think it's the right move i think the
president's absolutely
right but that's only part of what the
president is suggesting
nancy pelosi gave the members of the
house
just a few hours to reach 6 000 pages
of legislation she did that because she
had stuffed this bill
full of pork we are we are funding in a
coveted relief bill
we are funding uh two new museums to
women's history
we are funding uh social engineering
programs in in pakistan we are funding a
panel to examine the succession of the
dalai lama
all sorts of port projects in this bill
what the president is saying is
make america first bring america the the
make america the priority
so stop funding foreign projects in a
coveted relief bill
knock that out and take that money and
use it to
fund the and give the american people a
two thousand dollar check
if nancy pelosi does that i think she'll
get overwhelming republican support
she'll certainly have my support but
just to add a two thousand dollar
payment instead of a six hundred dollar
payment
to the port that's in the bill is just
unacceptable
but is she going to do that um
representative buck is she going to take
the pork out of there and all the
programs that she loves
i guess i'm curious is that what the
bill is going to look like is
well once again she gave us 6 000 pages
in a few hours to read it i'm sure we
won't have a chance to read this bill
before we vote on it
and the democrats will vote for it the
republicans want to see the bill if she
strips the pork
if she if she stops giving her pet
projects in the united states and
overseas uh this this money
she will get republican support but it
takes more than just an hour of debate
uh to understand the bill like this and
to fully examine it
so i i would hope that she would start
sending this bill out and letting people
know
that all these terrible projects are
being stripped from the bill
and that the american people are going
to benefit this is just a play
that that nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
are making to try to win votes in
georgia
let's let's just be uh you know up front
about that and it's a very cynical play
because it deals with something that's
very important
to the american people well we know
that's what they do they did the same
thing
before election day congressman is there
a way to separate the two bills the 900
billion dollars for coveted relief from
the 1.4 trillion dollar omnibus bill
which you can
which much of this is contained in and
the urgency created for covid gives an
opportunity for all the pork as you're
talking about
is there a way to just do covet as
republicans have talked about for months
at an even higher number than 600 and
then debate the rest of that stuff later
or at least get a chance to cut it out
it's a great point because nancy pelosi
actually had
brought other kinds of pork to stop this
bill from being
passed before the election she wanted to
help fund
the failing pension systems in
california new york new jersey
uh in other blue states she she was
involved she wanted to make sure that
the president didn't get a win before
the election
uh by uh sending out a check to the
american people so she has stalled for
months
to make sure this bill didn't pass and
now on the eve
of this bill passing she is going to
refuse to take out the port that's
necessary
to fund an additional payment that the
president is asking for
for the american people congressman just
a point of clarification i want to move
on to ask you about the chronovirus
vaccine but just as a point of
clarification
it sounds like when you're answering
rachel and and pete's questions
your support for the two thousand dollar
increase is
tied to reducing the pork in the
government spending
bill if that's not accomplished if nancy
pelosi won't take that out
i'm i'm reading between the lines then
you will not vote for an increase in the
in the covert relief checks i will not
vote for an increase in the coveted
relief checks that places a huge burden
on our grandchildren to pay back the
national debt the 30 trillion dollars in
national debt
that we have already accumulated
absolutely not
all right thank you for clarifying where
you'll vote on those bills that possibly
look like they're coming in the next
couple of days to congress let's ask you
about this
really quickly we know that several
members of congress like alexandria
ocasio-cortez have already gotten their
coveted vaccines
i'd love to ask you where you stand on
that first let's take a look at aoc and
some other members of congress
and where they've been on getting the
vaccine the covenant vaccine became
available to members of congress last
night
and we are urged to take it okay
that's it
there you have it she took the vaccine
members of congress were put toward the
front of the line where are you
congressman will you be getting the
vaccine have you already
i have not gotten the vaccine and i will
not jump the line there are health care
workers in america who need this vaccine
desperately there are
seniors and those with pre-existing
conditions that need this vaccine
i am a healthy young 61 year old man
i am not going to take this vaccine
until those who are
at risk take the vaccine and then i will
evaluate whether i'll take the vaccine
or not
at that point but i think it's a big
mistake for 30-somethings that are
members of congress to
assert their elitist position and take
this vaccine
rather than giving those who are
desperately in need of the vaccine the
vaccine it's very similar
to the discussion we just had about the
pork taking the pork out of the bill so
that americans can get that 2
000 relief
right well congressman um we know that
there are a lot of elderly people who
are suffering and dying of loneliness
in nursing homes and and and really
should receive that vaccine before
healthy americans so
uh and young americans so thank you for
joining us and and merry christmas to
you
thank you sir merry christmas merry
christmas